tip the balance you can play it with two
or the family
you each get you each get a little scale
right
you know like a little you know one of
those yeah right right and you put like
a kilogram weight in a bowl on the other
and it's the first one to make fill the
bowl
but you can only use bodily fluids
[Music]
so you can wean it vomit in it
so this is gonna be house if you can
produce a lot um you know
you should tune in to our show this
coming monday
yeah i play tip the balance samuel l
jackson just imagine the cover
the cover with granny going you know
hoisting up a skirt and then it'll be
lovely a waddington
waddington sort of family game we're
going to do it thank you for that
suggestion
there was a game this year i i i
invented another game um
i i like to um you know work sort of
11 till three then um i go to the gym
believe it or not
uh and then i'm in my pajamas with a
bottle of wine by about
six o'clock every night and i'm watching
telly
and um pajamas get old
and they they because men sort of like
fiddle they sort of wear out there don't
they
right they do right they do wear out in
that area
a hole appeared right and then i
discovered i could pull through random
little bits of it might be scrotum it
might be foreskin
right and so and so
i invented the game for ball right
sorry i'm sorry i was busy looking to my
i'm horrified camera
what is the name of the game again oh of
course you put a little bit out and i
and i'd say to my girlfriend jane ball
and she
she'd only get it right about 20 of the
time really
yeah so yeah you just pull it don't do
too much because it'd be obvious but
just a little in
just a little well you're ready you're
ready for it now
it is halfway out here he's in he's in
the
ball position yeah he's down
i like the perfect
do say that phrase here we have a phrase
in england he doesn't know his arse from
his elbow
yeah we know that we have yeah yeah um
it's for an incompetent person he
doesn't know what they're doing he
doesn't know he's after himself but he
would have to be incompetent and not
know that would matter if he couldn't
imagine that yeah it wouldn't stand up
in court i don't work yeah no you'd go
[Laughter]
believe it or not they can look similar
if you just take a little selfie
right we'll all do this right watch this
right all right and we've got a game
called ass or elbow
yeah if you want um i don't know so okay
i'll just take a picture
okay of my clearly my elbow yeah yeah
this is clearly
when you sort of manipulate it and sort
of crop it just right look at that
wait that way yeah
and you can look if you just
you can just put little random things in
there
right right what can i help you in any
way yeah look
just anything anything makes it look
just a little bit yeah like
or medical right look at this right this
is right
so
it's freaking you
you can eat peanut butter nutella
yeah just anything my mate showed me
that and he's a classical musician and
we did that for about
three hours but we were drunk it's great
just do it you should do this
we are going to do it's going to be we
don't you'd be great here you'd be oh
you'd have a great house
i love anyone tuning in just now just
rip it handy there's no time
oh that's amazing andy
right that is beautiful
that's he's got the double flap going on
oh my god
look at this oh that is
[Applause]
you changed our show ladies and
gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen it's a whole new
conan show from now on
acer elbow